Transcription factors that bind enhancer regions of DNA
and activate transcription, are called activators. And transcription
factors that bind silencer regions of DNA and
repress transcription are called repressors. Now in reality,
most genes are actually a mix of both
activators and repressors. Giving us a very fine
tuned gene expression pattern. Of course this is
called combinatorial regulation because there's a combination of
both activators and repressors. And a certain trait can
appear or disappear depending on the threshold of transcription
that we reach. For example, let's look at our
trait of lactose intolerance. If my hands here represent the
scales of a balance of lactose intolerance We're going to
look at how transcription can affect this particular trait. Over
here, we'll have lactose intolerance and over here we'll
have lactose tolerance. As a baby, many of us can
digest lactose in breastmilk. In fact, we can
do this because we have enough lactase being expressed
from the lactase gene. Having a lot of
lactase will allow us to digest that lactose, and
we won't show signs of lactose intolerance. In
fact, we'll be lactose tolerant. But as we get
older, gene transcription begins to slow or diminish
in some people, particularly those like Shao Lu. And
instead we reach a threshold, we reach a critical tipping point. Where
we have so little lactose that we don't have enough to digest
the lactose in our diet. And instead the lactose stays around and gets
digested by all that bacteria and we have symptoms of lactose intolerance.